good afternoon first of all let me
welcome all of you to our new forum this
is going to be our first lecture in our
new science technology and policy forum
at CMU as you've seen I'm sure in
previous email messages that through
these lectures panels and roundtable
discussions the forum aims to spark
dynamic campus-wide dialogue on
scientific and technological innovations
and their potential societal and policy
impact there's probably no better way to
kick off this science technology and
policy forum than to have my good friend
Jim Croce who's here with us today
I don't think Jim requires an
introduction I want to give him as much
time for this but let me just say a few
words as all of you know Jim currently
serves as assistant director of the
National Science Foundation for computer
information science and engineering game
he his role Jim is responsible for the
size Directorate of course with an
annual budget of 900 million and growing
right Jim
nine hundred fifty-four and growing as I
said in its mission to uphold nation's
leadership in scientific discovery and
in engineering innovation through its
support of fundamental research in
computer information science and
engineering of course state-of-the-art
cyber infrastructure and education and
workforce development as all of you know
while at NSF Jim of course is on leave
from UMass at Amherst he's been on the
faculty at UMass since
gosh 2004 1984 and he's been a
distinguished professor at the school of
computer science 2004 I was gonna say
2004 that doesn't sound right and of
course as all of you know Jim Jim is a
highly decorated distinguished colleague
well regarded in the community for his
research and education his interest is
broad computer networks architecture
network
Mintz sensor networks multimedia
communication modeling and performance
evaluation his co-authored a book
computer networking a top-down approach
which is in its sixth edition widely use
across the country but more importantly
I want to thank Jim for his service at
the National Science Foundation and also
for all the fresh thinking that he's
brought to this to this role at NSF with
that please join us at the podium and
let's give a warm welcome to Jim well
it's really really nice to be here is my
mic sounding ok ok great
I've been here before is sort of a
faculty member giving talks in the
networking group and stuff like that but
sort of my first first time here in this
particular official role here and so
what I'd like to do is I'd like to give
you sort of an overview of activities
going on within the size within the size
Directorate talk a little bit you know
big picture about what we're doing dive
down into a couple of programs that I
think in areas that I think will be a
particular interest to folks here and
then I I'd like to point out what I see
is some future challenges and you know
we don't just say challenges we always
say challenges and opportunities ok so
but actually before I get started
so this is gonna be like a little love
fest here I think between me and Farnam
so I you know Farnum said I'm bringing
in fresh thinking to the job I don't
know about that but because I'm
following for him as you all know he was
the ad of size before that I was looking
at this going over my slide almost looks
like a obituary I'm sorry about that but
really Farnum has given left me a size
18 pair of shoes to fill because he's
just done amazing things for the for the
foundation and for the size Directorate
in terms of the leadership and the new
programs launched some which I'm going
to be talking about today his
stewardship I mean we rotate the 80s
rotate through these positions and you
know I think we have a very strong sense
of community and history going all the
way back I mean I've talked to all of
the 80s from size going back into the
1990s to get their perspective
then I feel that like Farnum I'm very
much a steward of a very long and
important and proud tradition there and
the team that he's assembled there and
I've inherited and now we're bringing in
some new people too as other people
rotate out really a fantastic group of
people so I want to publicly so you know
him is your Provost right actually I had
an ad from SBE as my Provost and I will
tell you she is the best Provost I had
in 32 years at the University of
Massachusetts Cora Merrick was my was my
Provost and so I hope you have the great
warm fuzzy feelings for Farnum that I
had for for my programs
okay so I'm going to start at the very
beginning I'm a computer scientist we
all think top-down right and so I think
everybody here knows that the role of
the National Science Foundation you know
probably the most important thing
promoting the progress of science what
you probably may not know is that in the
organic act the NSF is also called on to
advance national health prosperity and
welfare secure the national defense and
so you know certainly first and foremost
as it shows up up there pushing forward
the frontier of science is absolutely
what we do and I want to well I'll come
back to that in just a second let me say
first of all I feel a little bit like
Forrest Gump you know you you sort of
end up at a point and you say like how
did I get here because all the good
things I mean so many good things are
happening now for our discipline and so
what you see up here these are five
presidential five ongoing presidential
initiatives where the White House and
OSTP says these are these are our
initiatives that are of national
importance so folks here know certainly
about the national robotics initiative
the the big data initiative the brain
initiative they're on July 28th the
president announced a national strategic
shooting initiative it's Randy here okay
so and Randy played a huge role
in creating that in his leaf from here
for OSTP for a year and then just two
weeks ago the president announced the
smart cities initiative and actually
Pittsburgh played a very important role
there your mayor was there at the White
House and and Farnam was on a panel
there so you know if we think as
computer scientists where do we sort of
fit in the national psyche and in the
administration's psyche about the
importance of what we do were really
there front and center so it's really
it's it's a I think a pretty special
time I can't really think I've been in
the field for some of you have been in
longer but probably not many of you and
I we're really at a tremendously
important time now so those are the
administrative priorities we have
continuing priorities within the size
Directorate securing cyberspace and I'll
drop down into some of these a little
bit later talking about computer and
network systems the work we're doing in
education and workforce development the
work going on and learning and
augmenting human capabilities and then
finally some of the theoretical
foundations of our field so these you
know this administration priorities
clearly we're tremendously important
players there and here some of our
continuing priorities okay so you know
in a sense that's sort of the big
picture of some of the you know big
ideas and big areas going on I want to
now move from the research you know
pushing forward the research frontiers
in these areas to just a couple of words
about economic competitiveness and and
the importance of our field for the
country in that sense so I know I feel
like I'm bringing coals to Newcastle
here right so you all get how important
information technologies has been to the
economy and here are just a couple of
figures that come from National Academy
reports but I want to focus not just on
the impact but sort of how that impact
happens and I'm curious here how many
people know what the tire tracks diagram
is
how about Brooks Sutherland diagram
that's what it was so I gave a talk at
Stanford last week they have a higher
percentage of people who have heard of
it than you folks but now you'll all
have heard of it and I said how many
people heard of the tire tracks diagram
and I think about a quarter of the
people and then I showed it which is
this and I'll talk about it in a second
and then a couple people shouted oh
that's Brooks Sutherland which it is
that's where it first came from and then
50 percent said they they'd seen it
before but I want to the reason I'm
putting it up here is I wanted to to
show you I mean this is a graphic
illustration of something incredibly
important and really a beautiful
illustration I think of the interplay
between what we do as University
researchers and the role of federal
government and in funding an enabling
University researchers what happens in
industry and product lines here so you
see these lines going up I'm going to
focus on networking here it's my area
and so what you see here is sort of in
networking starting in the 1970s the
notion of packet switching and you know
really DARPA was making the primary
investments here at the time and then
sort of going up through now this is
when industry started picking up on it
the Green Line is when this area became
a 1 billion dollar product area and when
it gets fatter that's when it's it's 10
billion and unfortunately what you can't
see here quite as well is there are
arrows going back and forth there and
those arrows that come from university
to industry and industry back to to
universities that is the flow sort of
the documented flow of ideas and people
that go back and forth and this is sort
of getting at the economic
competitiveness aspect of what I was
saying that ideas that are starting in
universities are maybe starting in
industry research labs cross pollinating
as people move as students move as
papers get published as systems get
built and ideas get taken up and and and
I really want to say I've traveled
around it's our friend from India here
right so I I've traveled around the
world a lot and I really think that this
is almost a uniquely sort of us way of
is really interesting collaboration
between universities and industries and
so I've said that for you know there's
networking software technologies let me
simply say you know pick almost your
favorite area of computer science so
this is this is actually the full
graphic from a National Academy report
if you were to Bing or Google or search
for tire tracks and computer science you
get you'd get this report and so across
many many different fields and with
companies that are sort of formed on
these technologies you can see what the
impact of our discipline is on on the
national economy and lots of different
technologies so one of the problems is
that this ends at 2010 we're updating it
now but you know one of the questions I
sometimes get and for and probably heard
this too is people saying oh you know
you can only take credit for the
internet for so many years and now it's
like what have you done for me lately
well and you know I get that right and
that's absolutely true you know if I
were to come over to networking and talk
about software-defined networking which
is already now itself a billion dollar
plus industry I mean that has its roots
actually in an expeditions project that
we funded and - that one of the very
first expedition's projects we funded in
2007 so I think there are really good
stories I mean they're not I mean
they're true right they're not story
stories there are really good arguments
that we're continuing to make those
kinds of investments that then have this
natural flow into industry and back and
forth but actually when people say what
have you done for me lately III give
that as an example but I also like to
this is actually a slide I got from
Farnham coming up it's like what we're
going to do for you in the future also
and so this is a graphic taken from a
McKinsey report from about two years ago
that talks about the top 12 economically
disruptive technologies by 2025 and I'll
read the stuff over here on the
left-hand side autonomous near
autonomous vehicles right
Falls to Newcastle advanced robotics
ditto
cloud technology Internet of Things
automation of knowledge work mobile
Internet over here you see 3d printing
energy storage materials and if you look
at that
I don't know through my eyes I look at
that and I say oh I see computing
everywhere through all of those right
and certainly in this column here and
you might think that oh these must be
the twelve most disruptive computing or
IT technologies absolutely not right
across all areas these are at least
McKinsey's prediction about what are
going to be the twelve most disruptive
technologies and so I think looking
forward our discipline also has a very
central role in terms of the impact that
it's going to have okay so that was just
I wanted to touch just a little bit
before we proceed on on some of the
economic impact of of the work that we
have trying to see how sometimes it's
hard for me to tell graduate students
from faculty but some of you look like
students to be and when we think about
you know where the jobs going to be over
the next you know 10 years so this is
from the Bureau of Labor Statistics 2012
to 2022 saying that 57 percent of all of
the stem jobs are in the computing
occupations so as far to mention I come
from Massachusetts and our last governor
did a billion dollar statewide
initiative in in life sciences and the
digital economy is still pretty big in
Massachusetts and so all of the you know
all of the computing and networking and
IT software companies are all saying
where's our love right you know where's
our our I don't know billion dollar
investment and we didn't quite get that
but it got ramped up which was great but
I think this speaks to you know the
importance of computing you know when we
think about where the job growth is
going to be and jobs are incredibly
incredibly important especially to our
students learn more these days and so
again I think it speaks to the central
role that we play not just in research
now but in education as well so when I
go out and talk about computer science
sight you know or sorry computer and
information science and engineering you
know I always like to leave this message
with folks that it's an exciting
obviously important impactful time to be
in our discipline okay so what I'd like
to do next is I'd like to dive down a
little bit sort of a little bit deeper
into some of the programs that we're
doing within size at NSF but I've been a
teacher long enough to know you
shouldn't just get up and start talking
talking talking talking so any any
comments are great oh hey arrow is going
back and forth yeah
okay okay
great point I guess I've I've learned
that as a faculty member when
interacting with industry sometimes I
think when I was younger I used to think
it's the brilliance of my research
that's sort of attracting industry and
stuff like that and then I think over
time I realized like okay they thought
that was reasonable but what they really
wanted was access to my graduate
students and and sort of the the
workforce side of things I don't maybe
you folks have different experiences but
it's it's absolutely true yeah any other
comment what about sustainability for us
and we are not moving in the right
direction in this country for instance
in Pittsburgh and you mentioned the
mayor yup we have three treys a day I
took them to rubrics work with 90,000
people they have 100 traits and within
10 minutes we have - between uh-huh and
we don't have to fly to Paris we take a
train which goes faster and the United
States is not pursuing this kind of
vision and when I was in a bar in the
Chinese after we makenai there yeah I
remember when the airport in Hong Kong
was being built a new airport in Hong
Kong thinking wow when's the last time
we in the US undertook an infrastructure
project of that size so I mean I guess I
agree with you I'm gonna get a little
bit I mean sort of coming back to what's
happening in cities and also
specifically what's happening here in
Pittsburgh and I want to touch on smart
cities and and that's only part of the
investment that I know you're talking
about okay and absolutely right and
that's gonna be driven by the kinds of
applications that are going to be using
that so an industry interest - so I'm
gonna I'm gonna spend I do want to spend
a little bit okay great
okay uh all right so I haven't worked
hard I'm sorry but you never want to see
an org chart but but just so that you
know that we at NSF divide ourselves up
in
NSF size we divide ourselves up into
four four divisions so the division of
advanced cyber infrastructure that's
actually a division that serves all of
science and engineering across across
the foundation and it's absolutely not
just being iron although we do have a
number of facilities including one at
the Pittsburgh supercomputer center here
that receive significant support so we
do have HPC but there's a lot of as you
just mentioned a lot of interest in data
networking and cyber security so we have
programs for high bandwidth connectivity
for campuses 125 plus of those Awards
recently and then software software
software software being just incredibly
important and I'll come back to that
when we talk about the BNs CI this is
our computing and communications
foundations this is where hardware and
software foundations communication
theory information theory reside and and
of course the algorithmic foundations
and then finally I guess this is sort of
what used to be my home Directorate
computer and network systems computer
systems and networking systems basically
and this actually this is the area if
you look at numbers of proposals coming
in and sort of sort of grant funding
pressure this division over here
information and intelligent systems so
this has cyber human systems is where
robotics machine learning all of those
topics reside it's it's certainly the
Directorate that we're seeing the most
growth in okay okay last or chart I
promise whoops
okay all right so a little bit about NSF
by the numbers just so that you you're
sort of familiar with it'll give you an
idea of size so so for our 2014 budget
you know Farnum mentioned 900 million
dollars we just closed out 2015 we don't
have the final expenditures those will
be about 925 for fiscal 2016 which we're
just starting but on a continuing
resolution 954 million is our is the
budget request you're probably most
interested in things like the success
rate so a success rate of
three percent and that's across all of
the programs that we have taking out
like workshop reports and travel grants
for students and Eagers and things like
that which are you know sort of a
hundred percent hit rates are very high
hit rates you know I'll say it's been
going down slowly over time our career
numbers tend to be a little bit higher
than that some of the other ones because
we've been really pushing hard to make
investments in our junior faculty in
some of the other programs it's
certainly lessened less than 23 percent
but that's what it is
across all of sighs maybe I'll just
focus here a little bit on people
because in the end as Andrew mentioned
it's all about people right and so
senior researchers 6600 senior
researchers funded approximately equal
number of graduate students and a large
number of undergraduate students that
are funded also so I know you all
probably aware of our research
experience from undergraduate program
which is a you know really very
important to but I mean it's across the
whole foundation and incredibly
important so that's a little bit of size
by the numbers I want to show you a
graphic just sort of to show you what
the these are the budget realities that
we live in and so you know what you can
see here is that actually in some of
these years the NSF budget actually went
down the size budget has been doing
relatively well
comparatively and so you see three four
five percent increases per year and
that's just showing the breakdown over
the different divisions people say sort
of jokingly that you know five percent
is the new doubling you know it's just
the budget reality that we face right
now and I want to come back later to
this issue of how we can expand the
opportunities for four ps in particular
by by teaming with other other agencies
and and with industry as well I believe
okay and there's the number you can't
quite see it but for fiscal 2016 our
budget request is 954
and I think this is the last graphic on
on numbers where does our money go where
are the where does the funding go well
first of all I guess the point here is
that 66 so two-thirds of the funding
that goes out from size goes to computer
and information science Computer
Engineering departments but a full third
of it is going to other engineering
departments that the sciences and
humanities and some of the
interdisciplinary centers and so I think
again I had a wonderful conversation
with a number of folks here right before
coming coming here about the
interdisciplinary nature of research and
I think especially here it's another one
of these coals to Newcastle I mean the
amount of interdisciplinary research
that goes on here pretty seamlessly as
far as I can tell me people just
naturally work together across
disciplines
you know I think that's where our
discipline you know a third of our
funding is going to disciplines outside
sort of the traditional computer science
discipline ok uh ok so I want to talk a
little bit now more about some technical
topics and and I was I was challenged by
our our director to give her one slide
about what size was about in one slide
and you had to explain all of computer
science and where it was going over 15
years how would you do that ok so I want
to I I love comments on this guy I've
shown it to her already but it was a
little bit of a challenge to put
together it's got an animations of
course because you can't do it just one
slide right but it's visually one slide
okay so we were talking about this in an
earlier meeting here about yeah we're
very interdisciplinary right but to be
interdisciplinary you need strengths in
your foundational areas right so we have
the core that of computing that we fund
through through through course
solicitations and and these are just
some of them I hope I haven't left
people out when I showed this to some of
the other folks at NSF and
and one person didn't see themself in
there I immediately had somebody in my
office like 30 seconds after I walked
out of the room and they're in there now
I won't tell you who it is so so so we
have the core okay and and here's a
thought experiment and and I know you
folks do these kind of thing project
yourself to 2030 and look back and say
what are the changes what are the big
sort of macroscopic changes in the
discipline that you see in 2030 looking
back to 2015 right so it's another way
of thinking about where's our discipline
going over over that timeframe and and
well let me just show you sort of how
I've been talking about this right so
you know certainly we have sort of the
technical hardware building blocks and
and so far you know it's primarily
electrical and based on CMOS technology
and I think that you know thinking
further ahead so you've all heard you
know you all know about sort of Moore's
law and maybe it's running out of steam
and we have different technologies
actually for pushing CMOS technology
forward more but we're not sort of
getting the the gains that we used to
get simply by miniaturization so
thinking you know on beyond electrical
if you will the physicalness of
computing may very well change and so
certainly you know molecular computing
quantum computing here are some ideas of
what computing might look like it you
know sort of far out in the 2030 time
frame this one I think is much easier to
realize if you ask depending on how old
you are or think about this how do you
think your grandkids or your kids if
you're young we'll think about computing
in 2030 right in 15 years so for me I
think about my grandkids my yet unborn
grandkids you know we think about
platforms right think about servers and
pizza boxes and and racks and PCs and
and and maybe phones and things like
that but that I know already that part
of the big vision here is that you know
computing I firmly believe that my
grandkids will know
think of computers as you know this
thing here that I type into but
something that just infuses the entire
environment right in this vision has
been around you know from Mike Weiser
and and others for quite a long time I
think we're finally beginning to realize
that as we see computing embedded more
and more and so I think this is a pretty
sure thing
smart vehicles and buildings I know
heard that a building that's going up I
forget what's being housed over there
but one of your buildings is going to be
completely completely sensor eyes
cyber-physical system smart cities so I
think this is changing if you will you
know the notion of what computing means
computing beyond the box here this is
sort of the interaction between humans
and computers so this I actually I
showed at my departmental retreat so
last fall I was a faculty member at
UMass and we're sitting around thinking
okay where should we we do this every
year where should we be making
investments what are really important
areas and when I got my five minutes to
pound on the table I was talking about
you know this was an area that I think
if we're gonna see the most profound
changes between now and 2030 it's likely
to come in these these areas where
computing assistive technologies for
people effective computing societal
informatics man man-machine interface of
brain machine interfaces and so I called
just called that on beyond HCI and then
finally I'm not sure we have stove-piped
applications but I wanted to sort of set
this up so I said we did you know this
this notion that integration exactly the
kind of things that I know are central
to what you folks are doing here that we
don't have stovepipe systems if you
think about smart and connected
communities the essence of that is to
get a network effect among all of these
different sectors that are united by
their use of
okay so that's my one slide that I
showed to the director any yes I was
gonna ask if there are any comments so I
I'm a self-proclaimed geek I like the
toys and shiny objects I wonder where
there are so many sort of human problems
and all of this sort of starts with the
opportunities for technology and science
but it's not where does the sort of the
challenges to sort of humanity sort of
come in here and effect it only it's
sort of like okay now we've got to
figure out how to right question two or
is there a way that it's brought in more
holistically so are you saying in the
sense if I think about how computing is
impacting house you know how our
societies form and functions or like
there's you know there are problems with
hunger there's problems with war there's
problems with that do we have anything
to say starting with that where do we
wait until we invent something cool and
then see where it can be applied yeah
well I I guess it's it's certainly the
case that if we think about you know
food energy and water systems for
example I'll talk about that in a little
while but there are many many
applications of computing here and I
guess I probably would have put that up
in societal application so I think
absolutely computing I mean first of all
just in terms of understanding
understanding climate understanding the
coupled systems that that form the
climate and then you know if I'm gonna
talk in a little bit about the Nexus of
food energy and water systems which is
actually a priority and computing plays
a very important role there so I guess
if I had to shoe her I mean I did have
that idea sort of up there in the top
right hand corner but I think you're
right in the sense that maybe because
I'll agree with you that I'm a geek too
that I sort of start from the center and
work out as opposed to thinking from you
know the bigger picture and top down
after the technology yes
a little bit and so a lot of things
awkward
a lot of these while engineering
advances a lot of you know what you have
hearing interaction Rob's only give
access to the data drives it yeah
companies large companies and they are
usually very happy if you go there and
work there for a year or two but then
after you go back it's a lot harder to
work on this data to actually experiment
because people get upset if they are
experimented upon his Facebook found out
the hard way and so how do we solve this
okay so I'm glad you raised that
actually for two reasons so first of all
I want to talk about that later under my
challenges and opportunities part but
but I want to say also
so you mentioned data I you know one
could say software one could say
security for instance and so there are
elements of computing that sort of cut
across this I mean when you have only
one slide you sort of have to take a
certain cut through it and there are
these kind of tech you know and maybe
technologies areas like data and the
importance of data I mean in all four of
these right and also the importance of
software throughout all of this security
throughout all of this so there is sort
of another orthogonal you know there's
another hyperplane going through this
that I could have talked about but but
didn't and I'll come back to that
question because I want to talk a little
bit towards the end about interactions
between universities and industries and
picture brains here okay so I'll come
back to that
okay all right so what I want to do is
next is I just like to dive down into a
couple of areas and give you just a few
examples I mean you don't want me to be
up here and telling you about all of the
programs that we have I mean actually it
doesn't even fit in a slide with small
fonts but so I'm just gonna I want to
sketch at a high level a couple of the
areas in which size is making
significant investments and so let me
start with smart systems because I know
that this is a priority item here and
certainly something that builds on
really ten years of work that's been
going on in cyber-physical systems at
the National Science Foundation and
within size and so these are the these
are the areas that actually we've talked
about a number of these before so smart
cities this notion here of a appear on
the top left-hand side of sort of a
closed loop system where we're sensing
we're bringing in data we're computing
over that and then there's some kind of
action whether it's steering sensors or
whether it's positioning resources or
allocating resources sort of that sense
compute actuate cycle smart and
connected health and we've talked about
both both of these two just a little bit
before so the foundations behind
underneath that there's a long history
of investment with in size in the areas
of cyber physical systems so we're about
to celebrate the 10th anniversary this
coming year of a program in cyber
physical systems and you know I think
the key words here pervasive computing
sensing in control of course but this
notion of high assurance right and and
so I think when we have these embedded
systems safety and security by design
has been sort of a theme here of cyber
physical systems and so that's where a
lot of formal methods are coming into
play in terms of design the National
robotics initiative so folks here I know
know a lot about that this is about to
celebrate its fifth anniversary in the
nose
of NRI 2.0 and maybe a continued
evolution so NRI was primarily you see
Co robots here that worked beside and
work cooperatively with people I think
probably a focus on autonomy will be you
know be integrated into this picture and
this is a great example where there are
a lot of cross agency efforts
so certainly NSF is very involved in
this not just size but engineering and
other directorates working with NASA
with USDA and also with NIH and I think
you know again thinking about relative
well thinking about two things right
thinking about budget growth which is
you know upwards but modest but also
thinking about how interdisciplinary we
are it's really these kinds of
collaborations that are going to be very
important in the future and thank you
for without being critical
I would allege that within something
like any ROI NSF clearly gets it I think
NASA does too
I'm not sure about the next two on the
list USDA and NIH I guess I could say
you know in talking I will tell you that
in talking with the program managers
here the USDA is relatively new and
something that people are excited about
I don't to say I don't know if they if
they sort of get that or not in the NIH
and robotic surgery and again I don't so
maybe I could ask you and what's what
what's the in what sense don't they get
and the the notion of robotics to do
something as delivered at surgery is
pretty disconnected from that
fundamental notion right because they're
primarily more disease oriented and
mechanism oriented so you know I think I
I guess I understand that comment and I
guess one thing that I've heard is that
NIH is sort of continuing to evolve and
maybe maybe that's just an area where
you know there used to be my
understanding correct me if I'm wrong
Farnham that there used to be almost you
know relatively little and now there's a
lot more collaboration between NSF and
NIH and so maybe it's just because again
computing related activities are
becoming more Howard about that too
that's just more areas of overlap now
what say anything I shouldn't put
anybody on the spot because we use so
much force in forest fires and and they
want to connect this to its building
industry so that we can use the wood not
to burn it but to use it for
construction okay and that's a very big
challenge because it doesn't deal with
the industry as it exists you know some
degrees so in a sense could be helpful
in that application you know III think
there's a very I mean you get to a very
important question right so we are
funding basic basic science research
right and now the question is how will
those science tools be used to inform
policy right and I think that the the
tools that we're building let me give
you a great example of this this has to
do with deforestation on a global scale
right there's an amazing project going
on an expeditious project at the
University of Minnesota using machine
learning techniques so that you can then
now look at aerial imagery and figure
out what are burn areas for example
around the globe right so that you can
actually look at series of satellite
photographs and and predict because you
can never measure you know boots on the
ground
measurements that's a case where
computing techniques are incredibly
important for even getting data in the
first place right that data can then
inform policy
I guess I'd argue that that's sort of
where that's sort of where our work is
handed off into the public policy sphere
I don't know if you're arguing that as
computer scientists or as citizens we
should be involved in that okay you're
okay so let me just say that I think
that computing has that important Kate
actually mandate right to help provide
the techniques to make us more informed
in our policy decisions but the policy
decisions are made outside the realm of
our own technical area right I mean it's
sort of a bigger problem that we engage
in as citizens okay last question and
then I'll move on yeah thank you NSF but
I want to take your phrase about taking
the results in science into policymaking
and look at the third bullet under cyber
physical systems and take as a cyber
physical system sort of everything
that's going on that involves computers
in computing and I spend a reasonable
fraction of my time terrified by that
third bullet right reliability safety
security usability and privacy and it's
it's trivial to cite from any newspaper
these days violations of all of those
essentially and I don't know whether
there's any way to improve from the
Foundation's perspective somehow
informing actual policy as opposed to
the research itself anywhere able or
able in the research to create
capabilities and then they seem to get
picked up very readily right because you
can make money on them and then these
control things which are very important
which are funding research on
left alone does it feel like a
disconnect I think maybe if I could
possibly mischaracterize what you're
saying is that you know we see that
there are these that there are these
problems we have solutions we throw them
over the fence and then they're just
sort of used and and that we we don't
infuse the policy discussion right and
and I don't know if Doug is here I mean
you you have on your your one of your
new chairs is he's like the perfect
person you know - so he's not here - I
mean he's addressing exactly those kinds
of questions right so that when so he
was the he was the CTE he was the CTO of
the FCC man fact I think it was the
first CTO of the FCC one of my former
students was also the CTO of the FCC and
when we were able to bring those people
into the policy discussion the policy
discussion is much richer and much more
well-informed but their their job is to
be engaged in that policy discussion
they bring them I think they bring the
knowledge and the results of what we're
doing so it can inform it so but I guess
I I sort of think of that as it's the
it's computer scientists involved in the
policy level type discussion okay okay
actually it's it's great to be
discussing this because I know that the
whole purpose of this forum is not for
me to tell you about what's going on and
then it's f-for what NSF is funny but
we're really talking about technology
and in science and policy also so I
appreciate those questions okay okay so
I wanted to say just a little bit about
sort of experimental systems research
going on here there was a project that
was started in probably circa 2000 six
or seven called geni which was a sort of
networking related project initially the
idea there was how to run experiments
meaning allowing people access allowing
people to sort of define their own
router functions and program them and
implement them at scale at national
scale notions of virtualization and how
you could sort of get slices all the way
across the network of routers that you
could program
and then in systems that would be
providing traffic into that not too far
after that the through OSTP and the
White House there was an effort that NSF
really took the lead on called us ignite
and the idea here was to get gigabit or
100 megabit plus connectivity out to the
edges to enable high bandwidth
applications to flourish right so really
just put the capabilities there one of
these build it and and help people come
in and and focus on those problems and
then most recently and this was actually
this was done under flaunted under
Farnum and I chaired the committee that
he appointed to sort of look into these
things so it's a little incestuous I
guess to put this up but NSF future
cloud that was looking if you will at
taking the idea some of the ideas that
were here in geni and then had already
been involved in evolved in geni to
include data centers and at the edge now
to extend virtualization not just of the
network but end-to-end through the cloud
and giving people access to experimental
systems researchers experimental access
to facilities all the way from bare
metal all the way up depending on where
they wanted to do do their research and
so we funded two of these efforts last
year one called cloud lab and one called
chameleon I probably don't need to go
into the details here they had to do
with resource sharing and virtualization
and Software Defined sort of everything
and I guess what the last thing I wanted
to say here so think of the pieces that
we're assembling here the network data
centers for experimental research these
are awards that we've made just within
the last several of them just within the
last few months maybe I'll call out
these two in particular which are
looking at experimental wireless systems
where you can use LTE over existing
phones and now what we've got is we've
got Wireless we've got computing we've
got networking all slice over to alized
and you have experimental access to that
certainly on a on a scale of
of a city I want to combine that now
with some activities going on in SATs II
are secure and trustworthy cyberspace
activity here it's a partnership between
size SPE social behavioral and Economic
Sciences education engineering and math
and physical sciences so a very
interdisciplinary activity here this is
funded at like seventy million dollars a
year so we we put a lot of money into
cybersecurity I will tell you that when
we go through budget exercises and you
probably do this at universities where
you say well you know if you cut so much
here what would you do less this is an
area where we never do less right it's
just a given that this is going to be
growing because it's it's so important
so if we combine all of these things I
think it sort of points out some real
opportunities so we talked about how we
have sliced virtualised deep
programmability within the network we
talked about how we've got connectivity
to the edge we've talked about how we
can now slice and virtualize clouds and
now I'm talking about experimental
infrastructure available to the research
community
we've got applications now coming from
smart and connected cities us ignite was
the project that I talked about just a
second ago
we've got software-defined radios
software-defined networks
software-defined interchanges the
infrastructure just all being
software-defined network functions
virtualization we've got these local
wireless test beds for instance that can
give us campus connectivity to
experimental LTE then linking us to
clouds at the edge and clouds deeper
back maybe we can get some regional
ubiquity so I didn't realize pit and see
him you were quite so close I was going
to use it as an example that you know
now we have the experimental
capabilities on a campus scale for
instance to be running LTE locally to
have computing behind it computing right
at the edge for very low latency
services and computing deeper back in
the cloud what happens when you walk off
the Carnegie Mellon campus in here
outside the footprint of that sort of
local Wireless umbrella you're walking
from here to
let's just imagine there's some space in
between where there's not you're not you
know under one of those two umbrellas
well maybe we can fall back on some form
of carrier participation here through
mobile network virtual operators so now
we've got all of these pieces sort of in
placed so if you think about this now in
a smart cities context we've got all of
these pieces in place for experimental
infrastructure for ubiquitous wireless
skin so accessing services and
applications wirelessly there sliceable
and they're programmable and to me
that's a mean it makes a great sort of
end to end platform for experimentation
for smart cities and and other
applications so just leave that with you
as a as an idea okay I was going to talk
a little bit there's been great
questions and I want to provoke even a
few more so I'm not going to talk I
don't really want to talk I don't have
time to talk about some of the work
going on in data science from data to
knowledge to to action I'll simply say
that this is an activity that's going on
across the foundation these are some of
the larger scale projects that have a
lot to do with data there's at least one
from every Directorate yeah
across the foundation so it's it's very
very important and I was going to talk a
little bit hour about our size specific
programs but I think I'll skip through
that and I'm gonna also skip quickly
just to say again because I know how
important this is here and I made the
pitch that this is sort of the area
where we may see the biggest advances
but certainly augmenting human
capabilities here and I won't go through
these and I want to sort of finish up
with education and then come back to
challenges one of the things that I
think Farnum and I and really the whole
foundation are incredibly proud of is
what size has done in the education
space especially in the K to 12
education space so starting starting
next year starting in 2016 there's going
to be a second eighth
exam called computer science principles
the idea here you know we have an
existing AP course and you know FERC as
long back as I can remember in our
College in our universities we have sort
of a very well-defined technical track
through our program you know where you
take cs1 so you has two data structures
I mean many of you may have been through
a program like that the goal here was to
really try and broaden broaden the
entryways if you will into computer
science as a major and and also address
the pipeline issue right so how do we
get kids interested in computer science
when I was in Massachusetts I was
involved in some of our statewide
education activities to push computing
there are a hundred and eighteen
districts in Massachusetts so if you
want to change something there's a
hundred and eighteen places you have to
go so that's clearly not scalable at a
national level if you really want to
create change and so Jan CuNi who's the
program manager who worked on this had
what I think was a brilliant observation
she said if we want to change what's
going on at a national scale we need to
embed changes sort of systemically and
something that crosses the country
writes Chris because we can't go to 118
school districts and in Massachusetts
and 200 in Pennsylvania and on and so
her I think her brilliant insight was to
say ah we can we can get this going
through the AP exam right and so this is
a new AP exam again that well I should
just tell you what cs10k stands for so
when Jan first told me about this in
2008 we were colleagues together at
UMass for a while and friends and she
said well you know the goal is to have
10,000 teachers trained to teach 10,000
computer science courses at 10,000 high
schools and I when she first told me
that I just said you're absolutely crazy
you know how could we possibly do that
well you know we're not going to make it
by 2016 but we're not going to be too
many years off in actually reaching that
goal right and you probably read that or
heard that the mayor of New York said
you know within the next 10 years every
single school in New York City so it's
1800 schools 1.1 million students will
have the ability to take computer
science courses right and actually this
particular computer systems principles
course is one that we're actually
funding a very large-scale deployment
and testing and evaluation of that in
New York City
I think it's an incredibly exciting
activity and I think we're gonna be
seeing the repercussions of this that's
that sounds bad
yes okay to the school room it has no
daylight no natural ventilation they
have no understanding of the environment
and if they are trying to teach physics
chemistry math and engineering they are
not in the environment which makes it
clear to them that these things are you
know so I mean we wrote a mans F
proposal on that issue on the RET yep I
know that program yes so I'd like to
work with you on this oh I mean III know
that program that I've had when I was a
faculty member I had science teachers
come and work with me that's how I know
the program but I'd be happy to talk to
you about that okay great sounds great
okay all right okay so we're doing a lot
with with alliances also so many of you
probably heard of nCWIT for example
something that got started actually
quite a while ago but you know with NSF
being a very key partner in helping to
get that up and running has really taken
off since then so I just want to say I
want to leave you with a message that
we're doing a lot in education also that
we're all very proud of and I want to
finish up in the five minutes that are
left just with a couple of challenges so
if you haven't read this report you
should it's it's something that you can
sort of sit back and just read on your
couch it's not hard to read but it's
sobering so you better be in a good mood
when you started I think because it's
really a call to action it's talking
about the level investment that we make
as a country in in science and engineer
research this this isn't working but
that sort of dark red line there is the
United States what's being plotted on
the y-axis is the percentage of GDP
that's invested in R&D by the federal
government and companies and you see
that we're sort of flat there at 2.5% we
see other countries Korea one which is
making an amazing amount of investment
that's the hockey sticking yellow one
there and China is in black on the
bottom right and and so this report one
of the things this report points out is
it's really calling for investments it
also calls for rethinking this industry
academia federal government relationship
that has been going on now really since
the post-sputnik post-sputnik era
so I wanted to talk a little bit about
collaborations with with with industry
and this is another I just talked about
one program here so the goal here is to
rethink what's what can NSF do in terms
of helping to deepen and extend that
partnership that's been so special in
the United States about the interactions
between universities industries and the
role of the federal government there and
I'll just give you one example of a and
actually Farnham started this the NSF
Intel partnerships which started in
cyber-physical systems now we have
another one in visual experiential
computing this is how this works that if
you're a PI and says do a security and
cyber physical systems you want to
submit a proposal so we had a
solicitation for it and on the
solicitation where all the NSF program
managers but but also Chris ramming who
who works at Intel used to be a DARPA
program manager and when you're a PI and
you submit your proposal you could
submit it and say oh I want to do this
the usual NSF way it'll have a panel and
nobody from Intel will see this or you
can check a box so it's opt in and you
can say I want Intel or it's fine for
Intel to look at this
so there's some Intel observers who sort
of sit on the side they don't actively
participate in the panel they you know
we go through the very rigorous and
you process that I think NSF is known
for and NSF makes its decisions and the
Intel managers then have agreed to match
the amount of NSF investment for their
with their own sort of bilateral funding
that goes from Intel flowing into the
university in in this area's IP and
things like that are negotiated between
Intel and the university and it's sort
of a second link if you will you know
here's the university here's Intel
here's the University
here's NSF and and to me this is a very
very attractive I mean I think it's a
really nice idea we're still learning
how well it works and and what some of
the gotchas might be but it sort of
highlights NSF's role as a convener
we're getting all the best ideas coming
in from the community and Industry is
able to sort of see those and make and
make they're sort of separate
investments so it's a way of augmenting
what NSF is already doing and sort of
again capitalizing on what NSF can do as
a as a convener okay so we talked before
about other collaborations the very last
thing I want to say and then then I'll
stop this I just want to say a word
about education and now not education at
K through 12 but education here at the
University so this was a talk that Ed
Lisowski and I gave at the last summer
at the Snowbird workshop which is where
all the computer science chairs and
Dean's get together so it was well I'm
sure you're seeing this here right so
this is our undergraduate programs and
oh there's this tidal wave of students
coming towards us right oh here are my
figures right so I I we just actually
became a school of information in
computer science at UMass right just at
the beginning of this academic year and
when we were trying up sort of push how
important computing was I mean you've
already done this right but we were
going through this right trying to
convince our provost and Chancellor how
important computing was for the whole
campus right and and and you know how
many and the number of students who are
wanting to take our courses are taking
our courses so these are our majors as a
function of time
and I was actually pretty good friends
with our Chancellor since I was I wasn't
in academic academic administration so I
wasn't ever asking him for anything
anymore I used to do that
and so we would just go have lunch and
so I was trying but of course I'm trying
to sell him stuff right and so I'm
trying to sell him on this notion of how
important computing is and I used this
graph and he said oh you know I know
I actually didn't show him this graph I
said well you know we used to be 500 now
we're almost almost a thousand we've
almost doubled so I didn't show him the
graph because you know it's more
complicated than that right he says oh I
know the graph you're talking about and
I know what the periodicity is and it's
about to turn over right and so we went
through we went through all these
arguments about why it's now why all the
things we've been talking about how
computing is is important for so many
different disciplines he got that right
of course because you know he's created
in college you know at the time he said
so I actually pulled this graph out
because I had it right and he said oh
you know I know you know you want me to
say you want me to say oh there's a
positive slope there and what I said to
him and I said you know actually a
quadratic is a way better fit usually
even more in us but in the end I mean he
made of the the university made a very
substantial investment and so I think
there's a tent
tangible cents on all campuses that what
we're seeing is student interest is
different this time around
students have broader interests where
we're getting people coming in I mean
I'm sure you're seeing this here right
we've have people coming in to our
machine learning class from all
different disciplines right and you know
graduate students from all across campus
trying to get into these courses and I
think it speaks to the the broad impact
that we have so let me tell you one
thing that keeps me up at night
so I've been thinking about this I think
I have personally seen because I like to
travel and talk to people I remember
three years ago going around and being
on a review committee at three different
universities where the Chancellor and
the Provost said exactly what my
Chancellor and provost said and I
couldn't convince them right and they
would deal with the the problem of or
the challenge of of over enrollments and
a lot of student
demand by allocating lecture positions
right because I was gonna turn over
I think that's changed right and if you
read around in the newspaper like you
know Harvard got a big endowment so that
they can add some dozen faculty members
and there are a number of other schools
I won't name them that are all very good
schools and are making you know
significant double-digit double-digit
investments in faculty I think we may
see the number of tenure-track faculty
increased very significantly three or
four years from now I wonder what that
means for us as NSF right that I mean
these are really good people right these
are gonna be really good people at
really good schools we're going to have
a larger group of P is we're gonna have
a larger impact for computer science
right if you read if you like to think
about university administration and
resource allocation and stuff like that
I'd encourage you to read this paper
it's really a picture of it not on a
picture of it rescuing biomedical
research from its systemic flaws it's a
discussion the people who wrote it are
are leading lights in their fields and
it talks about the consequences of
biomed having grown a lot and then
flattened out in terms of the amount of
research and so now for instance your r1
grant from NIH we're talking about NIH
before you're 43 on average when you get
your first solo grant right now III can
be honest enough with myself to think
about when I did my best work and when I
might have been most creative and we
might want to all reflect on that so
some of us are greater than 43 when that
happens some of us are less but you know
we've got a lot of fertile minds there
that aren't engaged in their own
independent research up to age 41 there
right and so there's a really really I
mean there's a lot of differences
between biomed and computer science when
I first read this I read it and I
thought it was interesting and then I
read it again and every time it said
biomed I put computer science and in my
mind and tried to argue why we were
different but it's it's really
interesting I think something we should
be thinking about
okay the last thing there's one tidal
wave here's another tidal wave that's
going to hit us I talked about cs10k the
broadening of computer of interest in
computing from from students and so
here's our regular traditional CS
programs here's maybe another tidal wave
we're going to see where we get students
who are coming in through computer
science principles they're interested
more in the application of computing and
maybe that's not an issue here but I
know at some schools we're still
teaching our pretty narrow technical
major we've got students who are coming
in with broad interests in computing and
how are we gonna how we're gonna handle
this what are we gonna do okay that
wasn't a very good animation anyway so
there's a number of universities that
are experimenting with CS plus X
programs or excellent
CS programs I'd be happy to talk offline
okay last slide this is sort of the
mom-and-pop Apple mom-and-pop and apple
pie slide you know again really thinking
about where we are as a discipline or
intellectual agenda the impact that we
have the importance of computing and
cyber infrastructure across all of
science and engineering learning we're
in a really really sweet spot right now
and you know we've talked since this is
about policy also you know we've talked
about the dividends to our nation of all
of the things we do both in research and
in education as well as the cyber
infrastructure so with that I'm sorry I
ran over just a few minutes I apologize
for that
but I thank you really for all the
questions in the for the discussion as
we're going along I'll be sticking
around for a while I'd love to continue
to talk
thank you for enough for the invitation
one or two quick questions earlier in
your presentation you showed a very
diagram with where the jobs were with
very crisp lines is there really that
crispo of a line between engineering and
computer or it I think there's a greater
and greater blend
you know blend all the way around right
so so that's a great point the point
well you had a microphone so everybody
could hear you know the point was was
that in that round circle that there
were some jobs that was just classified
as life scientists and of course there
are biomed people and even in computing
you may have a biomed background but
you're computing so these were simply
where the Bureau of Labor Statistics
through those lines they're not my lines
but you know somebody has to draw a line
somewhere you know so you should
absolutely take them as slightly movable
boundaries yes and advising
traditionally underrepresented groups
especially at K through 12 how are you
driving women in underrepresented
minorities into this field okay so great
question and let me simply point let me
point out just in terms of drawing
underrepresented minorities I I skipped
over this slide really really quickly so
one of the things I think one of the
lessons that's been learned over the
last ten years you know I talked about I
talked about this that across the
foundation we have this new project
called includes which is trying to do
that and when I went to Jan and I said
what's the one piece of advice I should
deliver to our director about how to
make you know how to make change in the
issue
bringing more diversity into stem she
said either be in it for the long term
or get out don't even start in the first
place right so here are the Alliance's
that we started so you know one of the I
think one of the other important lessons
from our history and there have been a
number of papers written about this
about systemic changes that have
networks so the networks can propagate
share best practices and and information
all of these are networks of large
numbers of institutions and people who
are working together so I mentioned
about with nCWIT which is women in
technology you know that was where at
the beginning intercept was sort of one
of the major players in that but that's
really now been embraced by a number of
the large tech companies and actually
NSF funding in that is now a much much
smaller piece of that because it's been
taken up by others but that network
still exists so we have a network for
that this is for this is the computing
Alliance for Hispanic serving
institutions another sort of separate
network that's been flourishing also so
I think the you know the answer is you
you know you create these networks you
plant these seeds you hook people
together and you help other people get
develop sustainability plans because I
mean you know the tech industry this is
a really important challenge for the
tech industry you've probably seen how I
forgot the size of the Intel commitment
to that but a lot of companies are
making these kinds of commitments and
actually working with I mean these are
not NSF only alliances here but they're
ones where you know we've played in the
past a very important role so I think
we've done a really good job seeding it
and staying with it you know for a
10-year seven to ten years since we've
been starting these things and they
continue to flourish and now I think
because of all the spotlight on
diversity issues in computing it's it's
drawing increased attention from
industry as well which is a great thing
well with that let me thank all of you
for joining us before we wrap up a shout
out to Howard Rockler who served at NSF
for four years
and under his watch national robotics
initiative and also the big data
initiative both for lunch thanks again
Howard for everything that you have done
with that I want to thank Jim for
spending the day with us for this
thought-provoking talk two days with us
that's exactly right
and I'm also for everything that you're
doing for our community thank you so
much